تتجول رغد مع والدتها واخوتها داخل معرض
الشهر الكريم الذي نفذته المؤسسه
الاقتصاديه اليمنيه لتوفير احتياجات
اليمنيين من المواد الغذائيه والتموينيه
باسعار مخططه ازدحام كبير شهده المعرض
الذي عاد فيه القطاع الحكومي لمنافسه
القطاع الخاص في بادره هي الاولى منذ بدء
الحرب
ما بين
التجاره النفسه واللي خارج طبعا في منافسه
هان ما بين التجار وما بين الحكومه باشياء
بسيطه طبعا كلها فارق اسعار يعني ما تزداد
عن ميه مئتين طبعا شيء جيدا وتحصل مثل هذا
المنافسه في مارب والاول مره التنافس داخل
سقف واحد في ثمانيه معارض رمضانيه بينها
مارب المدينه الاكثر ازدحاما بالنازحين
وفر لليمنيين فرصه الاستفاده من شراء
متطلبات شهر رمضان باسعار اقل من السوق
المحليه خصوصا تلك الاصناف التي توفرها
المؤسسه الاقتصاديه كل المنافسه الان وكل
التخفيضه الزياده الذي
الاقتصاديه يعني المراه الظروف الاقتصاديه
التي البلد القمح والارز والسكر والزيت
والحليب حرص القطاع الحكومي على توفير
كميات كبيره منها لضمان استمراريه انخفاض
اسعارها كمواد اساسيه لا غنى عنها في ظل
حاله صعبه يعانيها المواطنون بالنسبه
للمعرض بدايه خير ان شاء الله وفي اسعار
مناسبه
نقص البورنو نقص والمواد الغذائيه ان شاء
الله انه بدايه خير وبدايه منافسه حلوه
بين التجار ان شاء الله يكون مبشره بخير
من معرض مؤقت الى معارض بيع مباشره دائمه
تؤكد الجهات المعنيه سعيها لتوفير المواد
الاساسيه والتموينيه للمواطنين ما يضمن
كسر الاحتكار يامل المواطلون ان تنعكس
المنافسه بين القطاع الحكومي والقطاع
الخاص بانخفاض اسعار المواد الغذائيه
والتموينيه بشكل اكبر في ظل الظروف
المعيشيه الراهنه محمود الحميدي العربيه
مارب